rồi. Đợi tí.
À hôm nay là buổi ba
hôm nay là buổi ba.
đấy. Uầy tông ng đỏ trông sợ thế.
nhiều màu cũ.
đang bảo chỉnh
áo kia áo Dragon Ball rồi đúng không?
Nhưng mà trông hơi
cái
à mấy bỏ mấy viên đi
trên áo.
này. Con gì nhỉ?
thực ra là tìm đến kênh của mình là để
mà học để ôn thi xong rồi có người qua
nhưng mà cái việc là họ còn trụ lại với
ngành thì mình thấy a tùy tùy duyên.
Phải biết là dùng từ duyên bởi vì rõ
ràng là có nhiều người mình thấy có giỏi
nhá. người ta cũng có triển vọng nhưng
mà người ta không theo. Ờ nếu mà các bạn
đang thấy là mình đang livestream ở
không phải nhà mới mà đây chính là văn
phòng mình đang làm việc ở trên công ty.
Hôm nay mình livestream sớm hơn bình
thường và cũng nói chung là cũng lệch
giờ nữa bởi vì mình đang tiện ở đây mình
đang livestream không thì anh em lại bảo
là mình bùng học nhiều quá. Thực ra là
mấy ngày hôm nay là mình có học nhưng mà
mình học nhảy bởi vì phải diễn văn nghệ.
Đấy mình đang ngồi thiết kế lại cái a
ảnh thăm như các bạn đang thấy. Mình
thiết kế lại xong rồi mình sẽ sửa lại
đồng bộ cho các video khác chứ cái ảnh
cũ thì tôi cũng không thể ưng lắm. Đấy
mấy ông thấy ổn không? Thấy ổn đúng
không? Nó mất cái Tôi bảo nó hai cái màn
nhưng mà quay đi quay lại thấy mất một
màn rồi. Rõ ràng vừa nãy có hai màn nhỉ?
Thôi một màn cũng được nhở. Ổn mà đúng
không? Nhìn rõ mà đúng không?
Cái màn hình code này nó sẽ thay đổi
theo nội dung bài học luôn đấy. Không
phải có mỗi như kiểu hiển thị đơn giản
nhưế này đâu. Hiện tại thì bài một thì
đúng là mình chỉ khai báo kiểu dữ liệu
và phân biệt kiểu dữ liệu nên nó mới
trông đơn giản này thôi.
Ơ nhưng mà mất cái ghế rồi. Mất
mất ghế công thái học và
của tôi rồi. Ý tôi là bỏ viên bi đi
thôi.
Anh nhảy thử thì thựt ra là gần mấy ngày
hôm nay là bạn gái anh dậy nhảy. Bạn gái
anh anh thường hay kiểu trêu bạn ấy hot
tiktoker à hay nhảy. Anh quen bạn đấy là
qua ứng dụng App dating hẹn hò Facebook
dating đấy để mà nói chuyện lúc đầu xác
định lúc nào để nói chuyện là kiểu à nói
chuyện thôi bởi vì thời đấy là thời anh
đang rất là khủng hoảng rất nhiều cái
không phải khủng hoảng hiện sinh đâu nhá
đấy nhưng đại khái thì phải mãi về sau
thì mới bắt đầu kiểu nghiêm túc về tìm
hiểu các thứ xong rồi anh vẫn ấn tượng
nhất về bạn đấy đó là mẹ Con người rất
nhiều năng lượng anh kiểu đương nhiên là
xem qua các nền tảng mã xã hội ấy thì
thấy là bạn ấy là con người rất nhiều
năng lượng nên rất là thích đấy trông ổn
nhất rồi nhỉ. Áo vibu này tóc thì như là
không giống tôi lắm nhưng là thôi không
quan trọng. Đấy đây là tai nghe gaming
đấy.
Thực ra tôi có con tai nghe Sony này cơ
nhưng mà thôi bảo nó ngồi sửa lại hết
chi tiết quá không cần. Ghế ghế này ghế
công tho ở nhà tôi này. Áo thự áo tôi áo
T One cơ nhưng mà tôi nó muốn thể hiện
một tí wibu ở đây nên là thôi chắc là
cho vào chứ chứ T one thì bây giờ là
không ở trong hang đâu nên là chữ Wibo
mới hay trong má. Đây ngày 1 trên 100
được cái này phản ánh rõ là kiểu học
kiểu Java đúng không? Từ 1 đến 100 nhở.
chốt cái này nhỉ mấy ông nhỉ? Mấy ông
thấy ổn mà đúng không?
ờ tôi còn đang bấm hình như là vừa tôi
vừa rồi tôi bấm like nó nhầm.
Cái này là tôi đang live xem live cùng
mấy ông chứ không phải là tôi đang
đây đây đây. Đợi tí đợi tí. Đây đây đây.
Đây tôi phải xem phân tích ở đây để biết
được là đang có bao nhiêu người xem này.
Xong rồi
luồng mọi thứ thế nào này. Ok. Ờ ui tận
ba 13 người xem số thực ra là cũng không
đẹp nhưng không sao đây. Ổn đúng không?
Xong rồi mình lại phải chơi group. Hôm
trước có cái trang group trông xịn xịn
ấy mỗ tội là gì ạ?
Giao diện không dễ dùng nhưng mà ừ trang
này xịn
nó là resiz ảnh à hôm trước là resiz ảnh
đúng không?
Compress
online.
Hôm trước là dùng không phải dùng trang
này đúng không?
Trang này có khi là đơn giản cơ bản hơn
này.
Đợi tí
tốt hơn có nhiều. Đây này 2 m này không.
Trang kia có vẻ xịn hơn vì trang kia là
chỉ có
ấy.
các buổi live hôm trước.
May mới chỉ có hai ba buổi gì đấy dễ
sửa.
Đây hình như là hôm trước là cái này.
Xem nhá.
Hôm trước không phải cái này rồi.
Hôm trước cái trang web kia màu mè thật.
Chắc chắn là có thể đôi khi dùng vi code
hay gì gì đó.
nhưng mà có vẻ là chưa xịn mà cái hôm
trước.
bằng cái hôm trước. Hôm trước đổi kiểu
gì thành hai 200 đỉnh vãi chưởng.
đâu lại có khi nét hơn hôm trước. Mà
thực ra là cũng chẳng cần phải nét đến
thế đúng không?
đây.
người hơn nhỉ. Kiểu kiểu như người thật
ấy. Còn ảnh này thì hơi trông kiểu toàn
bộ là ảo nhưng thôi không sao.
Mình ở Wibo mà.
Ờ đấy
cho tôi
ảnh ngày hai
à.
Nội dung hôm thứ hai mình học sẽ là
string demo.
nhá.
Đấy anh thế tôi phải để ở đây rồi
hôm trước là tôi nhớ là học cả
hôm trước học gộp bài rồi
cái này cũng chẳng cần. Ờ tôi xóa xử cái
class này đi.
Ok, xóa xử đi.
Thực ra mình chỉ cần quan tâm đến Java
thôi. File Java thôi mình có cần chạy
đâu. Ừ.
xóa đi luôn cũng được. À gì nhở?
này mọi người ăn cơm biết rồi.
Nhưng không sao, tôi vẫn sẽ livestream
thôi. Tôi livestream để cho anh em xem
lại đúng không? Anh em còn ngồi học
cùng. Dạo này đâm người vào server vãi
chưởng. Xong rồi nhiều người cũng bình
luận mà.
là ngày 4
và ngày hôm mùng ngày mùng 1 thì mình
lại học cả
cái này với string po.
Tring p
là
th
kiểu này sẽ hơi xấu.
nội dung ở đây
nó là ngày 1 + 2.
ghi thế để cho mọi người hiểu rõ là chứ
không thì người sau sẽ không hiểu được
là tại sao lại có thế. Ừ trông không đến
nỗi nhỉ mấy ông thấy ổn không? Tôi thấy
ổn mà nhỉ. Con này thừ làm tốt phết. Con
này vẫn giữ được những cái chi tiết ảnh
cũ.
Con chatt thường hay tự động các thứ
thay thế.
Đấy, màn hình code cũng thay đổi, người
ta nhìn và người ta cũng hình dung được.
Được
xịn tôi đánh giá xịn.
Ơ ấn nhầm
đấy. Con này cũng được.
Xong vừa rồi mình à đấy mình nén bằng
con này.
cách a nó cũng không cách a.
hay vì liến.
[âm nhạc]
Ở công ty tôi làm về mảng về những sản
phẩm in ấn. Bên tôi cũng dùng AI thôi.
Bên tôi cũng gọi sang Open AI Chat TVT
với con chini này để tạo ra ảnh.
Dạ. Nhà nhà bây giờ phải có một tí tích
hợp AI cho nó sang không ạ? Đấy
trong chữ ấy.
Trên
thật
kiểu cứ thế mà dùng thôi.
Mỗi lần tôi ra lệnh prom như này là lại
tốn gì nhở? Ít nhất là tốn a nước để mà
làm à
kiểu gọi nhỉ
nước a gọi là quê sương mất rồi. Kiểu
nó có từ của nó là gì nhỉ?
Cái a
bình thường là cái a quạt tản nhiệt bằng
hơi nước à quạt t quả tàn nhiệt nước.
Đúng rồi đấy. Thì những cái lúc mình ra
lệnh như này ý rằng là mình tốn một ít
nước để mà nó kiểu tạm nhiệt bớt cho
máy. Đấy kiểu thế
lỗi tôi
chỉ thiếu mỗi cái này thôi. Ơ nếu đìý kỹ
là nó chỉ khác nó cũng cố thay đổi nhưng
mà nó vẫn giữ được cái tông đỉnh à. Thế
vẫn đỉnh đấy.
anh em cứ nói chuyện nhá. Tôi vẫn để ý
kênh chat mà gì anh em cứ nói nhá. Để
tôi ngồi sửa xong cái này rồi anh em
cùng ngồi học.
không phải mỗi lần gì cuối tuần lại ở
công ty. Ui sao em biết anh ở đang ở
công ty anh?
Anh đang kiểu kiểu nói chung là mày
tranh thủ thôi
Vừa rồi anh ngồi học nhảy chứ
đấy
nh. Sao ông không nghĩ đây là kiểu nhà
tối chắc thế? Có cái gì thể hiện nhà
không nhỉ?
Kiểu phong phong khác đấy. Hoặc là có
nét
lỗ hết bài
đấy. Bây giờ sẽ sang hôm trước học
string đúng không? cũng chưa học string
rồi. String builder và string buffer
nữa. Đúng. Tôi vẫn nhớ quá địch đấy.
Mình sẽ là à
cho tôi ảnh ngày 3
nội dung là
và string berfer đấy chuẩn đúng không ạ?
Còn gì nữa không ạ? không lại tốn hơi
nước
về sau ấy nghĩ chơi trò là kiểu cứ cứ
mỗi lần à
sau mỗn mỗi một ngày ấy thì ông kia mọc
thêm một tí râu kiểu giống kiểu tôi kiểu
già đi ý ông hiểu không kiểu thì đến
ngày 100 là kiểu thành cao thủ đại võ
lâm hiểu không kiểu dragon b là ông a
tiên lão hy sinh à tiên lão tiên tiên
sinh à? Cái gì? À quy lão tiên sinh đấy.
Đấy ông nếu ông xem truyện Dragon Ball
chắc ông biết đấy
nhưng mà ông hiểu ý tôi không? Đấy Quy
lão tiên sinh. Quy lão tiên sinh
đấy
trông trông có những ảnh chục chu ảnh
chục đấy thì ý tôi là thế. Lúc đầu lúc
đầu mình có thể là giống cái a lúc đầu
có tóc kiểu như này vì tao kiểu đến 100
ngày kiểu trong ngày java hiểu không?
Cao thủ đại võ lâm đấy.
Đấy lúc đầu một là mình thành cái thằng
kiểu như này. Hai lúc đầu mình chọc sẵn
cũng được đỡ phải chỉnh tóc chỉ chỉnh
dâu thôi.
không đúng không? vừa quên bảo màn hình
cố tốn thêm hơi nước rồi
đôi
cả màn hình code cho tôi còn gì nữa
không chắc đi
mọc thêm dâu không mấy ông chốt không
không mọc thêm dâu đúng không vẫn giữ
nguyên mọi thứ đúng không ghế tôi thấy
cài càng tối đi phải
mình có thể cho là ông này cài càng cụ
gù hơn chẳng hạn học nhiều quá gù lưng
À không ký công thái học chắc không đến
lỗi đâu.
Chốt nhá. Ok.
Ui mở ảnh vừa rồi không biết có dính bản
quyền hay không cơ chắc không đâu.
Google mà chẳng lẽ YouTube ấ đi đánh bản
quyền Google
từ 2023 đến giờ nhớ anh quá ha. Cá cá cá
cá. Ok.
Không nên tốn thêm nước.
Kể cả dù ngày thứ 99, ngày thứ 100 thì
tôi sẽ cho nó lên thành kiểu đầy thanh.
Còn ngày 3 này thì
còn sửa mỗi hôm nay với a
ok đổi
hip và stack. Uầi nghe thấy hay rồi. Hôm
trước mấy ông nhắc liên tục tôi chả hiểu
cái gì cả đấy.
Cho tôi ngày 4 h
Đúng đúng như là có khi tôi bắt đầu quen
dùng của Gemini rồi. J nó sẽ kiểu không
nhớ những cái ở trên ấ cho dù rõ ràng ở
trên vừa đề cập texch các thứ thứ ấ mình
phải nhắc lại prom đầy đủ thì nó mới
nhận. Nhưng mà đấy cũng là một cái điểm
hay là là
nó sẽ giữ lại được toàn bộ cái a
ở dưới. Nghĩa là nó giữ lại toàn bộ
những cái này này. Còn thằng chat vityt
nó cứ thay đổi kiểu thay đổi liên tục.
Nhưng mà bổ lại mình phải ghi nhập kiểu
prom rất là chi tiết lại. Rõ ràng đang
trong cùng cuộc trò chuyện đúng không?
Ui ông mà nhảy sang trò chuyện khác. Cái
thằng memory thằng này tệ cực sáng khẳn
cái khác luôn. Sao tự nhiên thầy có
class này
class với method để mà
có có nhắc đến stack với hip kìa. Đúng
không? Đúng không? Ừ chắc là thế. Tôi
nhìn thấy trông có vẻ là đúng đúng. Ông
nào biết về Java ở đây nhắc nhá.
Chứ toàn anh em PP chuyển sang không
biết gì cả.
Trông đúng đúng không?
Ừ tôi thấy trong hợp lý mà đúng không?
Khai báo nếu mà khai báo biến truyền vào
từ method đúng không? Thì sẽ là stack.
Em không nhìn được màn hình á. Sao nhỉ?
rồi không nói gì nữa. Ông lừa tôi đúng
không? Chôn chôn.
cả. Anh chỉ đang ngồi sửa lại cái a à
anh anh đang nói cái chữ ở trên này này.
Cái chữ ở trên này này chắc là bé quá
mọi người nhìn thấy đúng không? Đây được
chưa?
Ok chưa? Mình hiểu tôi cũng nhìn góc như
này mới nhìn được. Đấy anh đang sửa cái
thăm của mấy cái bài các thứ thứ bài cũ
và bài hôm nay nữa.
Thông cảm bây giờ mới chuẩn bị à th
chuẩn bị nữa bây giờ mới làm đấy.
Đáng lẽ chuẩn là mấy cái này là phải làm
từ đầu rồi để mấy ông xem luôn. Nhưng mà
tôi muốn livestream sớm để mà cứ cho nó
câu mấy ông vào đi. Chứ mấy ông có khi
là mấy ông sẽ nghĩ là 8:00 rồi mới live
chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì hôm nay live
sớm hơn mà.
Thấy tôi
sửa lại cái thăm của cái video này này.
Đây sẽ là buổi bốn học Java.
Đây sẽ là
Công nhận hai cực ý. Không biết mấy ông
thấy thế nào nhưng tôi học mấy ông và
mấy cái này tôi thấy thú vị vãi chưởng
thật
nên là cảm thấy kiểu rất hào hứng khi
học.
đó mấy ông tải lại sang đi ạ. thấy
thăm mới với a tiêu đề mới.
đặt, setup các thứ các thứ. Đây chúng ta
sẽ vào hẳn máy nhá. Ok.
À đầu tiên là hôm nay nhắc về stack và
stack thì tôi biết về khái niệm stack
rồi. Nó vẫn là ngăn xếp này. Nó vẫn thế
thôi đúng không? Ừ cái
đầu tiên thì nếu mà kiểu trong PP tôi
nhớ rồi chỉ sẽ biết về stack với kill
mà.
Không biết mấy ông có biết cái này
không. Cứ cho giả sử mấy ông chưa biết
thì tôi nói lại nhé.
Thì stack mọi người thường hay so sánh
nó giống như cái trồng đĩa. Tức là nó
chỉ là first in last à first in first
first in first out kia. Tức là sao?
Nghĩa là trống đĩa tức là sao? Nghĩa
mình cho một cái đĩa vào đầu tiên đúng
không? Xong rồi nhét thêm cái đĩa đĩa
đĩa đĩa trồng với nhau hoặc trồng sách
cũng được tùy. Xong rồi để mà lấy ra cái
đĩa ở ở dưới cùng thì thường mình sẽ
phải bỏ lần lượt từng cái ở trên trước
đúng không? Nghĩa là sẽ là sẽ là last in
nhưng mà first out đúng không? Last in
first out. Và cái này sẽ là last in last
out. Còn thì sao? Kill của nó sẽ
hình dung. Ơ xem
cấu trúc memô
qua tôi tra cấu trúc của một câu xin lỗi
của à trong Java.
À đây đây đây tôi sẽ gợi ý cho mấy ông
một cái nữa. Cái Natkin AI. Cái này là
tôi từng dùng cái thằng này để mà làm
PowerPoint bởi vì nó luôn mô phỏng ra xị
cực. Xị cực. Đếm giờ hình như nó vẫn
miễn phí phải xị cực. Đấy. Đây hồi trước
làm PowerPoint này thấy không? Đợi tí
nhá. Đợi tí nhá. Nhìn nhìn nhá. Đây cấu
trúc memory trong Java đúng không? Đấy
nhập. Enter.
Đấy sẽ soạn v rất rất xịn. Ầy bây giờ
thêm logo này nhưng thế này chưa đủ. Mấy
ông bảo tưởng anh làm thế nào cái này
cái này cho em làm được đúng không?
Không bình tĩnh bình tĩnh. Đây nhìn nhá.
Bôi toàn bộ đoạn này ấn cái này này. Đấy
đấy xong rồi bây giờ nó sẽ tạo ra một
cái ảnh trực quan để mấy ông nhìn.
Và cái này rất hợp để hồi trước tôi là
PowerPoint tức là chỉ kiểu để thuyết
trình ấy. Nghĩa là ông vừa dùng con này
để kiểu tạo ra một cái đoạn gọi là tài
liệu document đúng không? Đấy và trong
slide thì ông không nên có chữ vì slide
tôi chỉ có ảnh thôi thì tôi sẽ để mấy
cái ảnh kiểu như này. Nghĩa là nó rất ít
chữ và nó sẽ dễ rất dễ hình dung đúng
không? Xịn không?
được tí tôi nhé. Cái này cái này không
xuất ra. Ừ thích thì tí tôi bảo nó xuất
ra dạng à file ma down. Xong rồi tôi đẩy
lên cùng tài liệu trong kiểu GitHub hoặc
cái này xuất ra file PDF được thì phải.
Để đẩy cái này lên cho anh em vừa ngồi
xem vừa ngồi đọc tài liệu cùng cho nó
đẹp.
màu mè chính mà
mớ
nhưng mà tôi không biết tí vì gì về Java
quan trọng thế khi mà mình hỏi ai ấy mà
mình không biết cái câu trả lời đúng
không thì nó rất dễ chém gió ra cái gì
đó chắc là cái này nó không chém gió đâu
vì lý thuyết nó vững như ý tôi là kìa nó
mà trả lời cho ông một cái sai ông không
có đủ kiến thức để xác nhận được nó sai
ý tôi là như thế nghĩa là thường là bây
giờ kinh nghiệm không phải kinh nghiệm
nữa mà là
mà là bài cứ cho bài học xương máu hay
cái gì đó đi. Đấy khá là ông chỉ nên hỏi
AI khi mà ông biết được câu trả lời nên
là kiểu thường hỏi ai để mà chắc chắn
lại được câu trả lời này hoặc là nói về
lộ trình hay vân vân vân. Nói chung đại
khái là ông phải có một cái gì đó gọi là
kiểm tra nó, check nó validate nó. Đấy,
kiểu thế nghĩa là chỉ xác thực lại được
cái thông tin nó đưa ra cho đúng hay
không. Ví dụ một cái điển hình nhá. Tôi
đưa ra cái này ông là mấy ông ở đây biết
về Java, ông có thể nói lại với tôi là
nó đang nói đúng hay sai chẳng hạn. Thế
nhưng bây giờ trong trường hợp mà tôi
không có bọn ông, tôi chỉ có mình tôi
thôi, tôi lại không kiến thức với Java
thì rõ ràng nó nói tôi cái gì tôi rất
khó và xác thực trư khi tôi lên Google.
mà lên Google thì tính ra là Google bây
giờ còn bị nhược điểm Google đầy dãy
đúng không? Kiểu tự nhiên mình phải đi
ngồi sàng lọc lại thông tin các thứ thứ
chứ nó không trả lời đúng sai cho mình
được đúng không? Thế nên thường nhiều có
anh em chơi cái trò đó là hỏi con một
con AI này xong rồi mình dùng những con
AI khác để xát thực đúng không? Nhưng mà
nó vẫn có trường hợp là nếu mà vào cái
kiến thức nào đó mà không một con AI nào
biết mà một con AI này bịa thì những con
khác nó vẫn hoàn toàn thể bịa vì chẳng
làm gì con nào biết cỏ lúa bằng nhau mà
đúng không? Đấy nên là cách mà dùng con
AI để mà check để mà validate dự kiểu
kiểm tra về độ xác thực độ chính xác về
dữ liệu nó cũng kiểu
không đáng tin cậy lắm đúng không?
kiểu nhiều chữ cũng kiểu tương đối nhiều
chữ mà đúng không?
Xịn không?
này. Uầy đẹp vãi trưởng
đấy. Đấy xong nó còn thêm màu nhá. Thôi
cứ cứ nhảy không mộc như này chưa đủ
đâu. Đấy ông còn thể chỉnh thêm được.
Ông thể vào đây sửa chữ này gì đó này
đúng không? Đấy. Ôi thêm bao nhiêu thứ
này. Nhưng cái hay tôi thường hay bấm
vào đây này. Đấy. Tôi sẽ xuất ra nét
nhất này. Không có background để nó là
ảnh kiểu ảnh B B BNG là ảnh trong suốt
ấy. Đấy. Đương nhiên là khi mà copy ra
clipboard này nó sẽ thêm cái logo ông
thể tắt đi nếu mà ông mua bản gì đó. Còn
không thì
[âm nhạc]
hả
liều nhiều lý thuyết khó hình dung á.
Nếu mà ông chỉ hiển thị mỗi sáu cái xong
rồi suy ra hiệu suất của Java thì tôi
nghĩ cái đấy còn khó hiểu hơn đúng
không? Cái này nghĩa là mình không thể
nên bảo là bỏ bớt chữ được vì nó là lý
thuyết.
rồi tôi nói tôi có tin đâu chứ quan
trọng là bây giờ tôi hỏi mấy ông thì mấy
ông cũng phải cho tôi một cái tài liệu ở
đó đúng không? Không thì mình
ôi nhở chỉ có h với steak thôi nhỉ?
Không tại có ông có ông nào vừa nãy nói
là xem cấu trúc để cho dễ hình dung. À
chính ông chứ anh. Đấy nếu thế ông phải
nói rõ tôi đây tôi soạn lại một cái nói
rõ hơn nhá.
Đấy
không? Đây.
Ok chưa? Đấy so sánh mỗi hai thằng nhá.
Sau nó sẽ ra được một cái
khoe cái này mà.
chơi cái này để so sánh hai thằng
đấy. Ông muốn mom tôi nghĩa cứ cứ đơn
giản mà chơi đi. Quản lý bởi Gabit
Collector này truy cập chậm hơn, truy
cập nhanh quản lý tự động kích thước cố
định, kích thước động lưu trữ biến cục
bộ lưu trữ đối tượng. Xong
đùa đấy. Đây để rồi trao
cái gì nhỉ?
Đây chàng này
thôi.
Cái gì đấy? Ông bảo tôi tra hình ảnh nào
cơ? Ông lừa tôi đúng không? Hai bằng
tiếng Anh. Tra tiếng Anh nhá.
Ờ. Mem
memory
in Java stack and hip đây đúng không?
Ông bảo cái cái nào dễ hiểu đâu?
Cái này á cái này cũng tương đối dễ hiểu
này đúng không? Tương đối thôi.
dễ hiểu hơn.
Cứ cho là tôi thích cái con AI gọi là
mình mình quen thuộc mình thích cái gì
đó rồi nên mình dễ học thử cái đấy.
Cái này trông vẽ trông xấu quá. AI của
tôi vẽ đẹp hơn.
Ok nha. Ok pro.
không? Stack là chứa mấy cái
thôi. Tôi tôi chọn cái này đấy. Stack
lưu biến cục bộ dễ hiểu hơn mà
ở trong này rồi mà chiếu thế nãy giờ
chiếu thế.
Trong này chắc chắn ta dễ hiểu rồi.
Mh này.
tham số đúng không?
tham số nó là parameter
của method đúng không? Đặc điểm nhanh tự
giải phóng khi
nhìn mấy ông nhìn được màn hình bên này
vậy chưa
sao đợi đợi một tí đợi tôi một tí chỉnh
lạ
gì đâu nhưng mà kiểu
Đấy nhìn cho nó kiểu
tập trung đấy. Cái thế
th nhìn mặt tôi cũng chẳng quan trọng mà
mà tự nhiên nó phân tâm thêm một cái
khác rồi.
Ok. À tắt cái bên này đi.
Rồi
khi ra khỏi hàm. Cái này nó giống memory
ở trong PP.
Lỗi phổ biến stack over flow errow đệ
quy vô hạn.
chắc là kiểu gọi hàm với hàm thành đệ
quy thôi đúng không?
lưu stack h vùng nhớ hip
là tất cả object new một cái gì đó ok
sống lâu cần cbage collector dọn dẹp độ
phổ biến out of memory errow nhiều
object không thể giải phóng new một cái
gì gì đó biến p nằm trong stack bởi vì
khai báo bằng cái gì đó đây đúng không
biến biến a cục bộ object thì thực sự
lại nằm trong hip b trò đến địa chỉ ồ
đấy kiểu trong Java con trỏ hiểu không
nhắc hình con trỏ nhiều chỉ trỏ trỏ chỉ
chỉ đấy
object person nằm trong hip xong cái này
nó sẽ chỉ bản chất là địa chỉ thôi đúng
không
kiểu cái biến trong trường hợp này cái
này là biến biến á đúng không nhỉ? Nó
vẫn ừ nó vẫn gọi là biến. Ví dụ truyền
tham trị và tham chiếu
nguyên thủy này. Pass by value có copy
giá trị.
Cái hàm này
đổi nó thành 99 đúng không?
Cái này thì không đổi đúng.
Trong PP sẽ thế này.
nguyên thủy đi. Nó kêu nguyên thủy mà
đúng không? Tất cả m chị ạ học tuy là
kêu là đều là ngôn ngữ bậc trình à lập
trình. Nếu mà theo lý thuyết nhá thì đều
là ngôn ngữ lập trình bậc cao rồi kẻ C+
cộng 2C nhá. Đúng không? Bậc thấp là
chắc là Bascan có tính là thấp không? T
scan này vẫn cao nhưng mà nhớ là có cái
môn gì trước ở đấy nữa môn quên sử một
tên rồi đại khái cái trước đấy mới thấp
kiểu nó có tí nhị phân của em trong đấy
ấ đấy xong rồi bảng ý nhớ có bảng ai đấy
kiểu dùng axi code ấy đấy à
còn à bây giờ là ngôn ngữ lập trình bậc
cao rồi nhưng mà thực ra về sau nó còn
phân loại ra nữa đó là cái nào ngôn ngữ
lập trình tự nhiên nhất bởi vì theo Theo
như lý thuyết, ngôn ngữ, tập trình.
Đúng rồi, assembly. Đúng rồi, assembly.
Đấy, ngôn ngôn lúc đầu nhị phân là chỉ
máy hiểu đúng không? Xong rồi, đấy là
ngôn ngữ tầm trung bởi vì là giữa máy
với máy cũng hiểu một ít. Đấy, kiểu kiểu
thế nghĩa không cần biên dịch nhiều xong
rồi người không biết người hiểu tí nào
không như đại khái người cũng hiểu đấy.
Chứ người hiểu người mà chỉ nhị phân thì
đúng là chả hiểu được đúng không? Đấy,
xong rồi đến ngôn ngữ lập chính bậc cao
là tương đối dễ hiểu đấy. Nhưng mà nếu
mà theo lý thuyết như thế thì rõ ràng là
có những cái ngôn ngữ nào còn dễ hiểu
hơn so với cái C hay C+ cộng chẳng hạn.
Đấy, giống như là cứ cho là Scrat cũng
tính là một kiểu không hẳn là ngôn ngữ
lập trình nhưng mà sẽ kiểu dạng là danh
chẻ con học ấy. Tôi không biết phát âm
chuẩn từ đấy không? Scrap cái gì không?
Chắc mấy không biết cái kiểu kéo thả để
mà làm cái gì đó kiểu vòng lặp hay eo
hay cái gì đó ấy. Đấy.
kiểm sát ấy không phải thấp kiểu Ừ anh
hiểu anh hiểu nó đương nhiên Java không
phải ngôn ngữ lập trình bậc thấp nhưng
anh đang nói là kiểu nó là nguyên thủy
tức là chỉ là nó làm kiểu co ấy giống
như kiểu C hay C+ C+ hay Java nó là cái
co đấy do anh muốn về học cái kiểu như
thế như em đang nói đấy nhưng mà
tính ra là Java vẫn còn dễ học hơn C+ C+
đúng không? Đấy.
Thế nên là khi mà mấy người mà cứ hỏi là
anh từ PP sao không nhảy sang GO, không
nhảy sang hẳn cái kiểu mới hẳn đi sao l
nhảy về cái cũ giống như Java mình có
thể nhảy sang Python hay gì gì đó. Thực
ra là nó không phải là cái co này không
phải cái lõ không phải quay về cái
nguyên thủy này đúng không? Khi mà mình
quay về cái này xong rồi như em đang nói
là mình học mấy cái này xong mình nhảy
sang cái khác nó lại dễ đấy. Giống như
kiểu mình học PP là đang học ở lá đúng
không? Xong mình đi về. Đi về gốc thì nó
hơi quá nhưng mình đi về cái đoạn cành
hay thân đã xong rồi từ thân lại nhảy về
lá khắc thì nó sẽ dễ đấy. Nhờ
thế nhảy nhảy nói chung là cái này lúc
đầu bằng 5 này vào hàm này. Hàm này tuy
thay đổi giá trị cho nó nhưng mà nếu mà
trong PP có cái trò là kiểu dùng dấu con
trỏ như này để mà trỏ đến a cái giá trị
ơ trong này trỏ được đúng không? này tôi
chưa cài gì nó không báo gì cả chắc là
tôi chưa cài. Đấy con trỏ này xong rồi
thài tự nhiên được gán giá trị. Nói
chung là cái đấy hơi vi phạm quy tắc bởi
kiểu nó không nó gọi là không clean code
đúng không? Cái blackit đấy không ổn
đúng không? Đấy tự nhiên kiểu thằng này
đang bằng năm xong rồi qua một cái hàm
tự nhiên thằng này bằng số khác.
có cái trò đấy không biết trong này có
không? Tôi nghĩ là có khi có
ơ đúng rồi này. Object object truyền vào
nó thay đổi đúng trong PP thì cũng đúng
truyền vào chạy xong hàm xong đúng
object cũng thay đổi thật.
thể
hàm này nó kiểu nó trỏ thẳng vào cái h
để mà sửa sửa giá trị đúng không?
Còn cái a
có thằng này có cái cùm trò đến
Ok, hợp lý đấy.
bộ. Đây là khai báo kiểu global là toàn
toàn cục này. Đấy thì sẽ nằm trong í. Ok
được cái đoạn này hiểu
stack là để nó giống kiểu RAM à kiểu
kiểu thế đi là kiểu là kiểu truy cập
nhanh và
chắc là nó sẽ hạn chế kiểu
cộng
thì sao mà tường minh bằng được
ha.
thứ thứ hay như nào? Thôi chưa hiểu cái
đấy lắm. Hay là ý ông là kiểu cộng cộng
nó từng minh nhất đúng không? Đúng. Nếu
mà tôi nhớ hồi đấy là người ta bảo là
hồi mà tôi học à trên đại học à thế là
tôi không học đại học cao đẳng về mua là
lập trình thì đương nhiên là nhắc đến
bài con trỏ thì người ta sẽ kiểu dạy ở
trong C+ cộng hơn là họ dạy dạy trong
Java
học bên Java này cũng tương đối để
Hiểu được rồi đấy. Thực ra nội dung một
buổi một ngày thực ra ngồi chém gió hơn.
Ngồi chém gió bao lâu nhỉ? Ngồi sửa cái
kia. Ngồi chém gió cái kia cũng phải
à bây giờ khoảng thời gian rồi. Tôi còn
đang không xem được thời gian. Đại khái
là ngồi
ra là mới
đây ngồi chém gió tầm gần 1 tiếng đồng
hồ đấy từ 7 gi
nhưng mà thực ra là chỉ học mọi thứ rất
là nhanh nhở.
không biết cái sao cơ. Trong PP sao nó
chỉ là nhân thôi. Còn dấu và kia là con
trò thì tôi biết trong PP còn trong Japa
tôi cũng chưa dùng. Đấy. Tôi tôi cũng
không muốn. Trong PP tôi đã cố hạn chế
dùng con trỏ rồi. Nó không tốt lắm.
Chẳng qua là có những lúc là phải dùng
để mà kiểu tối ưu cứ cho thế đi. Kiểu
bất đắc dĩ đi. Đấy. Hồi trước là có lạm
dụng nhá. Hồi trưa kiểu khi biết lạm
dụng kiểu hồi đấy sai kiểu hồi đấy ngựa
non háo đá kiểu dạng là cứ cho là nhìn
thấy nó ngầu nhìn thấy nó ngắn hay vân
vân. Đấy, thử sử dụng rapper class.
Có bài buổi một học rồi đấy. Còn bây giờ
để áp dụng thì tôi nghĩ là sẽ có buổi
vừa nãy có ông em bảo là mới comit lên
bài tập
nhưng mà trước mắt thì tôi nghĩ là tôi a
đang học theo kiểu cứ cho là học cưới
ngựa xem hoa cũng đúng đi bởi mình vẫn
đang chỉ học lý thuyết chưa làm bài tập.
Giờ tôi đang a
hay để ngồi nghĩ bài tập nhỉ đúng không?
Cái này chưa tính là bài tập. Cái này
chỉ demo thôi để cho hiểu thôi nhỉ.
Ông em vừa nãy có cho tôi bài tập nhưng
tôi chưa biết được là sẽ là bài về
số sau khi truyền biến vào method.
in khác gì? Ồ để tôi thử hỏi câu đấy
xem. Câu hỏi hay đấy. Cảm ơn ông nhá.
Được. Tôi cũng thắc mắc cái đấy luôn.
Xem thử.
anti Gravity Kit. Tôi sẽ khoe mấy ông.
Không biết là mấy ông a biết cái khái
niệm kit này của trong a trong cái AI.
Tôi thỉnh gần đây cứ cho là tôi bị
không phải FOMO vẫn là bị cái gì nhỉ? Bị
cuồng cái gì đó đi. Nghĩa làm gì ạ? Tôi
đang bị rất là cuồng ai đi. Tuy là hồi
trước là tôi đã không quan tâm về hồi
trước đặc biệt hồi cứ cho là hồi dùng à
IDE à trên đi e là đủ ấy. Kiểu PP Storm
ấy là nhất đủ rồi. Không cần phải cùng
nó một cái th vài cái tiện ích gợi ý
thôi chứ không phải kiểu chạy đua xem AI
thông minh hơn hay là mình kiểo vân vân
ấy. Nhưng mà bây giờ là cũng để ý hơn và
cũng dùng hẳn những con nào mình thực sự
mình cảm thấy tốt. Đấy ví dụ bây giờ
chuyển mấy ông thấy luồng hồi trước tôi
từng chia sẻ chuyển qua luồng khá nhiều
ấy thì và bây giờ còn nhắc đến cả Asian
skin nữa tôi cũng có nghe nhiều bởi vì
tôi tham gia mấy cái nhóm nhận đến AI
nên là nó cũng bị tác động tâm lý nhiều
ấy kiểu mọi người dùng ai cũng dùng ai
cũng ai cũng nhắc đến đấy cứ cho mình
phô à đấy kiểu thế mình sợ bị bỏ rơi
đúng không sợ bị lỗi thời Mình ở dân
công nghệ mà. Đấy, xong rồi mình cũng
tìm hiểu xong rồi thấy là ừ nó về cơ bản
thứ nhất nó miễn phí đấy nhá. Chưa nạp
đồng nào cả. Đấy, cái thằng này thì cái
này thực ra là để mà nói giải thích dễ
hiểu hơn thì ra nó cũng chỉ là viết hộ
cho mình prom và ngoài ra đương nhiên là
có thể viết prom hoặc là nó tự động chạy
thêm một cái gì đó nữa nhưng mà bản chất
là mình vẫn thể làm à tự làm điều đấy.
Chẳng qua là bây giờ nó tự động chạy cho
mình.
Đấy,
thằng antiravity này nó mới có và tôi
đang dùng antiravity
mục để mà lưu vào. Mỗi tội là mình phải
tự tạo. Và thằng antiity này có có một
người Việt luôn vừa mới chia sẻ.
Đây là
antiravity kit đây đang miễn phí nên là
cảm thấy hay phết. Tôi dùng link
công nhận J2 kiểu sale tốt phết. Nhìn
này. Cái này Facebook không nói nhá.
Trang này mấy trang này ok J2 lên mà
trong khi đó là cái thằng này nó lại
chuẩn là phải hit hub phải đứng đầu.
Theo tôi thì thế vì rõ ràng là anh em
cộng đồng mà đây hit hub còn chưa nhìn
thấy đúng không? Vẫn chưa thấy cái hitub
nào đây. Uầy vợ chiều nay 300 giờ lên
400 nhanh phết.
Thì đầu tiên là anh em a trên này có rất
nhiều cái skin nghĩa là đại khái là nếu
mà để đọc skin đây để tôi thử cài cho
mấy ông dễ hình dung. Thế là coi như là
xong bài hôm nay học rồi nhá. À đâu chứ
ông kia nói nữa nhưng mà đợi đợi tí tôi
chia sẻ vì t tự nhiên tôi nhắc đến hàng
ngày nên là tôi cứ bị cuồng chia sẻ.
Đợi tí đợi tôi nhận thích thoảng hơi
gọi nhở lặc đề một tí. Tôi cài cái này
rồi xong bây giờ chỉ cần CD vào thư mục
mình xong rồi cài thêm cái này.
Đấy để tôi thử chạy thử demo mấy ông
nhé.
cũng chỉ học thôi. Tôi nhớ có mỗi hôm
đầu tôi nói nhiều nhất bởi vì hôm đầu
tôi học hai bài.
thôi.
Nhưng mà qu tôi vẫn lười hơi. chưa có
bài tập và chưa làm
gì nhỉ? Cái mình đang bên CD bên a Java
đây. Tôi ngồi gõ cho mấy ông luôn.
CD này, Java này.
Đấy, xong rồi chạy cái lệnh này đúng
không?
Tôi vừa nãy tôi cài rồi. Hãy cài thử
trước.
Đấy. Đấy. Xong rồi. Thực ra là bản chất
là nó sẽ tạo cái thư mục như này.
Đấy. Thư mục này có đầy đủ. Nếu mà ông
đọc kỹ vào thực ra nó file MD thôi. Đây
là như này. Nó là bản chất là một cái
prom để cho
hơi ít quá.
là
skill và ru và agent. Agent thì tôi chưa
biết nhưng tôi chỉ biết được là ru này,
skill là con AI này nó sẽ tự động đọc
của ông. Nó tự động đọc. Đây ông có thể
vào xem nhá. Đấy cái này tôi để có lobal
mặc định không nó làm gì nhá. Đây nó tự
động đọc cái ru ở trên mini này. Đấy mà
skill thì tôi thấy là chưa có cái giao
diện của thằng Anty hiển thị ra. À tôi
ăn ăn rồi. Tôi ăn rồi mới dậy được không
hết sức mất. Đấy nhưng mà cái workflow
này là gì? Tức là chỉ là đây nó sẽ kiểu
cứ cho luồng luồng hoạt động đến một cái
gì đó đi. Ví dụ giả sử giả sử tôi demo
luôn ông thể khai báo brainstorm như
này. Đấy động não đúng không? Cứ cho
brainstone và động não. Đấy xong rồi. À
đợi tí tôi ghim cái này lại nhé. Đợi tôi
một tí. Ok. Ờ vậy đang nói gì nhỉ? Ông
kia hỏi về cái trên này đúng không? Ok.
À có bạn tôi tìm hiểu về
đây
sửa trong file này cho tôi. Giả sử dùng
Gini nhá. Bình thường tôi không thích
con JM này lắm. Bình thường tôi dùng
Cloue anh em biết Cloude code tốt hơn
đúng không? Nhưng mà trong vài trường
hợp con Jini này, thứ nhất là cái lượng
con lượng contexech của nó, token của nó
đang lớn nhất triệu thì phải. Mấy thằ
kia có 100.000 hoặc là 200.000 thôi.
Đấy. Thứ hai là
về đọc về làm giao diện và đọc tài liệu
thì tôi thấy con này đang tốt. Và thứ ba
nữa đó là nó bởi vì trong cái bộ này nó
đang viết được cho con Gemini rồi. Còn
những con a kia thì có vẻ đang chưa
viết. Có có vẻ tức là mấy con này vẫn
đọc trung hết cái tài liệu này thôi
nhưng mà tài liệu này vẻ đang truyền cho
con Jindi. Thì mình thử nhỉ? Thử nhá.
Đấy.
Ok không? Ơ à gọi đến này. Thực ra bản
chất là nó cũng gọi đến cái file MC down
thôi. Ok cũng hiểu
đây. Thì tôi thích dùng anti gravity bởi
vì nó luôn hiển thị cái luồng nó đang
nghĩ đang làm cái gì đó như này khá là
hợp lý. Nếu mấy ông biết tiếng Anh đây
nó sẽ cập nhật cho một cái T thường là
một cái gọi là checklist to do list. Đấy
đôi khi nó hiện tôi dùng cái chế độ plan
này nữa nó sẽ lên có một vài trường hợp
là nó sẽ lên hẳn một cái plan, một cái
kiểu một cái kế hoạch để mình có thể
kiểu xác nhận confirm đúng không? Thậm
chí là mình com comment vào là mình nên
làm cái à đây đây ví dụ plan này này.
Đấy kiểu như này comment vào là kiểu như
nào đấy abc vào đây để nó làm chuẩn hơn.
Đấy khi như này xong rồi mình sẽ proceed
mình sẽ bấm đôi khi là để nó tự động cái
này được nhưng nhiều cái thì nó vẫn mình
vẫn nên theo theo tôi mình vẫn phải xem
xác thực qua rồi mình mới post.
không? Nói giải thích rõ đấy. Demo
tạo ra object mới không sửa object cũ.
này. Đợi tí đợi tí.
Nhưng cái kiểu này là bất biến nên là
không thay đổi giá trị của object cũ
tạo ra một object mới và gán cho biến
này là local.
Ồ
đúng cái này nói chung là B thì vẫn là B
không đổi. Cái này tôi hiểu à
nó là bất biến nên cái này là 88.
này gán vào
nó tạo một object mới và gán là biến
local. Tức là con này nó sẽ vào stack
đúng không?
con này vẫn sẽ là 88 nhưng mà con 88 này
nó sẽ là
gọi là như nào nhỉ? Nó là một object mới
và nó ở trong
stack à đâu trong h đúng rồi. Cái con a
con này phải trong h chứ nhở new mà đúng
không? Nó new một object mà
khái là theo tôi hiểu nhá là trong híp
vẫn còn cái con
đấy đúng rồi không không không không
không không không không không không
không không
à đúng hai con hai con chứ sao đổi được
không?
Thế để tôi thử hỏi đây nhá.
Ờ
Vậy giờ trong hit có
hai object
10 và
88 hay
con này đang trong này là 10 rồi này.
Con này đang là trong híp rồi đúng
không?
công ty không anh?
trên 17 triệu. Nếu mà đi thực tập một
đoạn trên 17 triệu thì ừ giống như bạn
kia nói công ty lo
thường công ty lo
bao nhiêu phần trăm ấ tôi không nhớ lắm.
Tùy thường công ty ấy bạn phải deal với
công ty vì có khái niệm lương road với
lương lương gì đó nữa
câu chảy là gọ có hai object tại thời
điểm dòng code chạy giá trị 10 đang được
biến B ở trọ đúng rồi đúng rồi cái này
biết nó đang ở trên này vốn dĩ nó đang ở
trên này N
nếu tôi đổi đâu anh ngồi ở công ty đổi
thì
sao?
Đúng rồi. Biến 88.
memory sẽ thay đổi hoàn toàn.
Khi mà gọi kiểu này sẽ tự động
lấy số 10 ra xong rồi biến vào. Đấy thì
trong trường hợp này cái này nó sẽ lưu
vào stack đúng không ạ? Biến Nguyễn Thủy
hoàn toàn nằm trong stack, không lưu vào
trong híp nữa.
sau cô áp dụng nhiều không.
Ok, cảm ơn ông nhá. Ví dụ rất hay, rất
đúng lúc.
đập đoạn này đau đâu.
Đây, tôi sẽ truyền lên a
để mà hôm sau hôm sau buổi năm là còn à
buổi xă buổi năm có rồi này.
Bắt đầu từ buổi sáu là cũng phải ngồi
soạn lại dạng các thứ thứ thử. Hôm nay
thực ra chỉ cần livestream thôi mà tuy
có ít người xem nhưng thực ra là
thựt ra là mấy ông tôi tin là mấy ông
vẫn có xem lại và có những ông ngồi học
đồng hành cùng tôi bây giờ đang có nhiều
ông bình luận buổi một cơ.
Thế là ổn rồi.
Thôi tôi cũng chuẩn bị té đây. Ui mày
đau đầu mệt.
Mấy ông còn tâm sự gì nữa không ạ? Không
tâm sự tôi tạm comit lên nhá. Tôi không
phải sửa nhiều phết tôi sẽ ghi đã. Ờ
update
tôi sẽ như này một cái riêng một cái
này. Còn cái này sẽ là bỏ bỏ đi đúng
không? Sẽ là
remove un đấy. Xóa những cái không sử
dụng không có tâm.
Tú xem á. Chắc là anh có tuy là bình
thường thực ra là anh
không biết được mọi người đã từng kể mọi
người chưa nhưng thực ra hồi trước là
tôi từng không thích bóng đá lắm vì rất
rất nhiều lý do đấy
nhưng đế như là vẫn có lòng yêu nước và
xem cùng mọi người xem bóng đá kiểu
không khí của mọi người rất là vui. này
ông kia bây giờ mới bình luận á. Thôi
tôi nghỉ rồi để ông khác nhá. Để ông
khác ông bình luận ông comment hẳn vào
trong git của tôi đi. Ông đến lúc ông
comit vào trong git của tôi rồi. Ông anh
em nhìn thấy git mà đúng không?
Tôi chia sẻ link git đi mấy ông thấy
chưa nhỉ?
Git hub nhá.
trên git hub của tôi có đấy
có không nhỉ có không tôi vẫn chẳ biết
cơ
thôi cái gì
chăm chỉ lên chúng ta cùng học cùng giúp
nhau tốt lên đấy ờ gì nhỉ nói gì đấy nói
chung là xem
xem bóng đá cùng mọi người cùng không
khí vui và đặc biệt là đã thấy còn mấy
lần tôi xem ví dụ năm ngoái tôi xem nhá
à năm ngoái xem vô địch ừ vô địch à châu
Á đấy xong rồi vô địch SEA Game vừa rồi
đúng không? Đấy, vẫn nhớ mà. Đấy, nên
hôm nay tôi nghĩ là tôi có vía đấy. Chắc
là tối có thể xemấy.
Còn nếu mà tối nay mà à thôi không nói
gì, tốt nhất không nên nói gì cả.
Nhưng
với với ai à
cập nhật. Đây chỉ cần ghi cập nhật là
được.
Ok. Đẩy lên.